-Ladies, listen up.
We had a Hot Girl Summer.
And -- whoo! -- did we kill it.
But now it's getting
a little chilly outside.
-A little chilly. Brrrr!
-Well, I'm here to tell you
that the weather
may be getting cooler,
but we're just heating up.
Megan Thee Stallion, J-Fal.
-What up?
-Drop the beat.
-♪ Starin' outside,
all the leaves are changin' ♪
♪ Feelin' kind of cold, can't
stop complainin' ♪
♪ Days gettin' shorter
with that setting sun ♪
♪ Guess Hot Girl Summer
is really done ♪
♪ Then my phone rings,
and I look to see ♪
♪ It says "Megan Thee Stallion"
on the caller I.D. ♪
♪ She says... ♪
-♪ Jimmy, you're not making
any sense at all♪
♪ After Hot Girl Summer
comes... ♪
-No. You're not saying...
-♪ Hot Girl Fall, bitch ♪
♪ Yeah, it's finally here ♪
♪ It's the season to get cozy
with a pumpkin-ass beer ♪
♪ Grab a cable-knit scarf
and your trunkiest sweater ♪
♪ 'Cause the summer was dope,
but the fall's even better ♪
-So, wait.
Megan, can I do
Hot Girl Fall, too?
-Um, of course.
Hot Girl Fall is for everyone.
-If I do Hot Girl Fall,
is it called Hot Guy Fall?
-Uh, no.
-Okay, that's cool.
-♪ Hot Girl Fall
is a state of mind ♪
♪ It's a jack-o'-lantern
filled to the brim with wine ♪
♪ It's sending sexy pics of
your turkey breast ♪
♪ It's you and your dog getting
matching vests ♪
♪ Getting lit as hell
on a hayride ♪
♪ Spending all my cash
baking mad pies ♪
♪ Roll my turtleneck
to my hairline ♪
♪ This is Hot Girl Fall,
this is real time ♪
-♪ Gonna go to Staples,
gonna stock up ♪
-♪ No, he don't go to school,
but who gives a [bleep] ♪
-♪ Got a 2-inch binder,
a 12-month planner ♪
♪ A three-hole puncher, and
a handheld scanner ♪
♪ Make it rain the club
with these stacks of dough ♪
♪ I got a hole puncher, girl,
I'll make it snow ♪
♪♪
-♪ Hot Girl Fall, bitch ♪
♪ Yeah, we havin' some fun ♪
♪ And you know for Halloween,
my costume will be a pun ♪
♪ Said nothin' makes me hotter
than some temperate weather ♪
♪ 'Cause the summer was dope,
but the fall's even better ♪
-Yeah. Black Thought
on the track.
-Let's do this.
♪ The fall's the best season,
there is just one reason ♪
♪ I wear the same thing from
New York to Ibiza ♪
♪ I can be myself
when I reach for the shelf ♪
♪ Basically, I wear
one pattern and nothing else ♪
♪ Plaid shirt, plaid belt ♪
♪ Plaid pants,
and a plaid kilt ♪
♪ Gingham, tartan, tattersall ♪
♪ Houndstooth, plaid,
I own them all ♪
♪ Madras, Glen plaid,
windowpane ♪
♪ I've got plaid
inside my veins ♪
-Wow. That was intense.
-No, you do you, Tariq.
That's a plaid king right there.
-Catch me at J.Crew.
How about that?
-♪ Hot Girl Fall, bitch ♪
-♪ It's a Hot Girl Fall ♪
-Summer was just a preview.
You heard it here first.
MTS, J-Fal. Yeah.
Hot Girl Fall.
-And get your flu shots,
mother[bleep]